send it over to you all right thank you
jillian and thanks to cisco for
sponsoring this segment uh boom bang
fine foods and cocktails recently opened
in henderson and they're now serving
brunch here to tell us more is chef and
owner elia boomrad welcome back to the
show thank you so much for having me
back i'm so excited to be here it's
great it's great to have you back so the
last time you're here getting ready for
the restaurant to open we've been open
for a couple of weeks how are things
going things are going great honestly
the neighborhood is just embraced
embracing us so good people are so
friendly they're so happy families young
people older people everybody like it's
just such a nice neighborhood to be in
and they're being so nice and it's just
you know i'm cooking with love and
people are liking it so it's going good
well we love you it's boom bang brunch
is what it is guys offer brunch what do
you have on the brunch menu yeah so we
honestly we make all of our pastries in
house we have the cinnamon tumbleweed
our coffee roll
uh our house-made baguette and this is
all made in-house
stuff yes we make everything from
scratch um it's 10 30 to 3 p.m saturday
and sunday saturday and sunday and then
the rest of the week we're open from
four to ten happy hour as well and uh
yeah we are on the 215 and by a verdi so
easy to get to is it to get great buzz
about the restaurant this is this right
here so this is right here so enticing
what is that that is the huevos con
chorizo so it's super easy you know we
put like two eggs organic eggs chino
valley we try to get like only the best
for you guys and then i have my chipotle
marinara that we make in-house from
scratch i just love what you mentioned
about the eggs where are the eggs from
chino valley so you put thought into
every single ingredient oh yeah eggs
where everything comes from you're
putting a thought behind yes yes
something that if you're gonna eat like
over easy you're safe okay and then we
have our house-made chorizo that we made
also with biller sport
it's all antibiotic-free
and we pre-cook it so at the end it's
just a quick sizzle you know it goes in
the deck oven where we make our pizza
and uh
it takes like about eight minutes
to cook and what's your background too
because
last time
television background too because last
time you're on tv so many people were
actually calling the front desk saying
that's she's from top champion yes i am
from so you've got television experience
great cooking experience and now this
fantastic restaurant yes yes i've been
very blessed thank god you know we're in
a good position and i was able to open
with my husband and it's just like a
nice dream come true so and that one you
spent a lot of time i think i think i
need to try something here yes you
should and this is our coffee glaze it's
made with like mexican coffee liquor
it's super delicious it's something i
created for bung bang and this is the
recipe you just created on your yes
yeah i wanted to make like a
something really heavy on coffee you
know like mexican style sure and so it's
like a brioche and a coffee roll mixed
together i gotta wrap it up here but i
gotta i gotta take a bite of this before
we wrap this whole thing up cause it
looks so good
let me uh let me read this first because
i can't read with a mouth full of food i
want to thank you and cisco for
sponsoring this segment check them out
at 215 and valley verde for reservations
call 702-478-6200
or visit them online at boom bang
restaurant dot com or actually this is
boom bang restaurant and take a bite of
this return.com yeah
a parade a flavor in your mouth it is so
good thank you so much